you have some experience with possession
[Applause]
yes more than I'd like an exorcist movie
creeps under your skin and gets you we
pick up the story of Victor and his
daughter Angela a man who's raising his
daughter alone
hey be home by dinner I love you good
morning Mr Fielding Angela and Catherine
have been friends they're both at the
age where they're just finding
themselves me and Catherine doing out
there in those woods you're just walking
and walking
their family is in a sense are opposites
of each other Victor's put church and
Faith behind him the other parents have
faith they have Community wherever those
girls went they brought something back
with them
the film is dealing with the
vulnerability of Parenthood with a child
that's dealing with possession have you
ever seen anything like this
wow no but there are people out there
who have
thing character that I created 50 years
ago I thought she said 50 Years of
Living who has she become Ellen burstin
really blessed the project Chris McNeil
gonna have her first confrontation with
a demon in many years
don't be scared we've met before
I thought you can be taken over by a
force that's inside
there have been possessions throughout
history
it's not just in one location or one
religion or one culture it's Universal
one girl lives one girl dies
[Music]
God played a trick on you